en tout cas tout à commencer par ce jeu
là en fait part aux médias c'est ça veut
dire horizontales verticales diagonales
c'est un jeu de d'alignement de quatre
billes de la même couleur type puissance
4 d'accord voilà ça c'est le premier jeu
dans lequel vous vous lancer en 2012
vous démarrez ça en 2012 mais pourquoi
vous lancer là dedans
au départ qu'est ce qui vous a pris si
vous avez un peu tout plaquer pour ça on
n'a pas joué on a un peu tôt il a quitté
en tout cas les boulot qu'on avait avant
voulais faire quelque chose ensemble
on avait plein d'idées on a pensé avoir
à tenir un restaurant faire pas mal de
choses et puis on s'est dit le jeu en
bois on a vu pas mal de trucs on si ça
peut être sympa de remettre ça un peu au
goût du jour
c'est vrai qu'en 2012 quand on est
partis qu'on a dit on va fabriquer des
jeux en bois en vivre il n'y a pas grand
monde qui croyait en notre projet
maintenant à cb je tourne bien se porte
bien on a pas mal de création n'a
développé pas mal de nouveaux jeux on
reprend des jeux anciens du piolet
grenouille qui est derrière nous ça veut
dire quoi vous vous vous regardez ce qui
a pu exister une époque qui n'existe
plus éventuellement vous inventer des
choses aussi assez c'est quoi vos jeux
en fait les deux les deux ce qui nous
plaît aussi
donc on va soit développé une gamme ou
alors reprendre des jeux qu'on aime bien
vous des souvenirs d'enfance aussi un
peu non non c'est plus de recherches sur
certains jeux qui ont pu qui se tient du
moment qu'on marchait ou
on peut les créations tout simplement
nous notre coeur de métier c'est
vraiment les jeux de réflexion leur a
tout à l'heure découvre atripla ce fait
fermé la boîte d'autres jeux mais
regardez maintenant ils sont
enregistrées ce qui en fait donc ça
démarre avec aux médias fermer la boîte
c'est bon mais un peu embêté leur quoi
en voilà un joueur qui est très ancien
oui un peu plus d'une centaine d'années
donc un jeu de comptoir et un jeu plein
panda compter aux enfants aussi donc ce
que vous votre but c'est quand même de
faire des jeux en tous cas ici dans
votre boutique de proposer des jeux tout
public en fait on a une gamme qui va de
la naissance donc grâce à l'artisanat
duras oui c'est à dire que vous ne
l'êtes tout ce qui est autour de brunoy
tous fabriqués à tous annoncé encadré en
fait d'artisans du jura parce qu'on ne
peut pas tout fabriquer la semaine ne
dure pas assez longtemps qu'il faut
fabriquer il faut aller voter ce soir
était de jouer a fallu le réel et non
non je suis ok avec les gens avec notre
clientèle
donc c'est pas désagréable non c'est pas
désagréable et donc effectivement vous
êtes allés chercher ce que vous
n'arriviez pas à faire vous ici chez
d'autres experts du bois qui sont les
jurassiens la jouets en bois c'est un
peu falot au coeur dû à la source en
fait un du jeu oui j'ai en bois et et
pour le reste je dirais vous vous créez
vous imaginez moi ou vous reprenez enfin
jouer des anciens celle ça donc ça
effectivement
c'est super pour apprendre enfin pour
compter pour apprendre à raconter aux
enfants et aventures de cinq ans après
et puis après c'est un jeu de bar un jeu
de comptoir un jeune estaminet donc
ces voix-là grands modèles et petits
modèles donc on verra par la suite
parce que cette indication c'est ce que
voilà c'est ça le triple triple sept
scènes vraiment polti le petit dernier
aussi dernier donc on l'a celui-ci est
sorti en octobre de l'année dernière
donc juste avant les fêtes de noël
seront il faut aussi qu'on se
renouvellent on a des clients des
clients qui qui nous suivent énormément
donc il faut leur proposer une nouvelle
gamme de jeux donc voilà le triple sept
un petit jeu familial tout simple facile
à jouer et pareil à partir de 5 ans et
pour personnes adultes et plus vous avez
des petits et vous avez des petits
formats mais aussi des grands
effectivement on en parlera là il ya un
an un jeune aussi vous avez repris ça on
nous a demandé pas mal il n'y a plus
aucun fabricant de lingerie en france
donc on les fait vraiment avec le tour
en bois les boîtes sont en bois il
vraiment totalement en bois les toutes
les filles ont les bois sombre et comme
on avait plus personne accusée d na
jaune en france commence et du bore
offert des nachos donc
repro afrique aussi bien à john bond est
justement vous parlez de fabrication va
aller voir un petit peu comment ça se
passe dans l'atelier je voulais juste
préciser une dernière chose c'est que
les jeux qui sont faits ici sont
également pensé pour les malvoyants et
ça c'est a remarqué est à noter et c'est
effectivement au marquage